a habit is a fixed way of thinking that
leads to automatic behavior but then if
it is we don't have to rethink again and
again what to do
it just happens and can have good side
effects but a bad habit can also hurt us
or hold us back from progressing
although like anything we can learn and
unlearn them but first let's try to
understand where they come from
habits are made by experiences creating
fixed ways of thinking inside our brain
to explain this let's compare what
happens inside your brain to what
happens on a farm there is a farmer
named Joe his vegetable garden the
chicken shed and a mailbox every morning
farmer Joe first walks to the vegetables
then checks on his chickens then
collects his mail and then walks back to
the house after a few days of this
routine his trace becomes more visible
on his farm after a few months the trace
becomes fixed pathways not only on his
farm but also inside his brain
one night Joe has a magical dream where
he discovers his love with all living
creatures the next day he sets all of
his chickens free the funny thing is
though instead of adjusting his behavior
he still walks blindly from the
vegetable garden to the chicken shed the
trace on the ground and inside Joe's
brain is now just too deep to leave the
path of habit we have to go down a new
road this takes time and multiple
repetitions of our new desired behavior
and willpower to keep going a habit is
often a response to a certain trigger
which is followed by a routine and
usually ends with a reward this is also
called a habit loop Joe's trigger is the
vegetables as soon as he waters his last
tomato he starts his next routine to
automatically walk to the chickens his
reward is to find eggs and because
rewards release dopamine and
neurotransmitter that makes our brain
first happy and then hooked we get stuck
and can't let go anymore
Joe's sister lives in the city she has a
funny habit whenever she hears her phone
she automatically looks at the screen
most of the time is just a random
irrelevant message this happens even if
something far more important was
happening right at that moment the sound
from the phone triggers a routine and a
hope for a sweet reward and some of that
addictive dopamine to change a habit
journalist Charles Duhigg recommends
redesigning the habit loop say you like
going to the movie theater but whenever
you do you eat too much of that sweet
popcorn in this case your trigger is the
popcorn stand that you pass by whenever
you go to the movies your routine is
buying that popcorn and your reward is
snacking during the film to change your
habit you could keep the trigger and
keep the reward but replace the routine
instead of sweet get salty popcorn later
maybe even fruit if a problem gets very
serious remove the trigger stop buying
movie tickets if we can't leave our
phone alone we can turn off all the
notifications and if we have friends
that get us into situations that can
trigger a bad habit we can make new
friends that don't some habits are
tricky procrastination for example there
is no clear trigger routine or reward it
just happens habits like that can be
changed in tiny steps that lead to small
rewards next time you procrastinate try
to make some short breaks in which you
focus your trigger can be the full hour
on your clock once you hear it focus on
your work even if it is just for five
minutes after reward yourself for the
piece of chocolate the very first day
you do that you will already create some
new traces in your brain and the next
day some more after a few weeks it will
be easy to walk down that road
many small steps added together make a
big difference over time after all we
still have our entire life in front of
us and to become successful good habits
are probably our best bet as the famous
poet John Dryden wrote we first make our
habits and then our habits make us tell
us have you ever learned or unlearned a
habit please share your experience in
the comments below
you